and what Noom did which I'll never
forget is he knew that I was the biggest
Jim Carrey fan in the world now I'm not
going to go all into it but Jim Carrey
is talented in a way that you can't
practice or rehearse what a god-given
talent I was fascinated with him and
Noom knew that and he called me up and
he goes Dave um he says I'm doing a
movie with Jim
Carrey do you want to meet him and I
said [__] yes I do and it was the first
time I could remember since my father
died being excited
and the movie was called man on the moon
I didn't know any of this and in this
movie Jim Carrey was playing another
comedian I admired the late great Andy
Kaufman yes and Jim Cary was so immersed
in that role that from the moment he
woke up to the time he went to bed at
night he would live his
life as Andy Kaufman I didn't know that
when they said cut this [__] was
still Andy cauan so much so that
everybody on the crew called him Andy I
didn't know any of that I just went
there to meet him and when he walked
into the room where we were supposed to
meet I scream Jim Carrey and everyone
said
no call him
Andy and I didn't understand and then he
came over and he was acting weird I
didn't know he was acting like Andy
called me just like hey how you doing
and I was like
hello
Andy
now in hindsight how [__] lucky am I
that I got to see one of the greatest
artists of my time immersed and one of
his most challenging processes ever very
lucky to have seen
that but as it was
happening I was very
disappointed cuz I wanted to meet Jim
Carrey and I had to pretend this [__]
was Andy Kaufman all afternoon
he was clearly Jim Carrey I could look
at him and I could see he was Jim
Carrey anyway I say all that to say
that's how trans people make me
[Applause]
feel here we
go
now if you guys came here to this show
tonight thinking that I'm going to make
fun of those people
again you've come to the wrong
show I'm not [__] with those people
anymore it wasn't worth the
trouble I ain't saying [__] about trans
people maybe maybe three or four times a
night but that is
it tired of talking about
them and you want to know why I'm tired
of talking about them because these
people acted like I needed them to be
funny well that's
ridiculous I don't need you I got a
whole new angle you guys will never see
this [__]
coming I ain't doing trans jokes no more
you know what I'mma to do tonight
tonight I'm doing your own handicap
jokes well they're not as organized as
the
gays and I love punching
down there's probably a handicap in the
back right now cuz that's where they
usually make them sit
[Applause]
there I came here to laugh of
transgender
people I didn't know this [__] was
going to make jokes about us come on
y'all let's get the [__] up out of
here
he